it was early Monday morning when
Regulators announced the end of First
Republic Bank and what they hoped was
the end to a crisis of confidence in the
U.S financial system
banking giant JP Morgan stepped in to
purchase the california-based banks
nearly 104 billion dollars in deposits
and 229 billion in assets before the
stock market opened
JPMorgan CEO Jamie dimon spoke with
analysts about the deal no crystal ball
is perfect but this part of the crisis
is over First Republic had been
teetering on the brink of collapse in
the wake of two others Silicon Valley
and Signature Bank amounting to some of
the largest bank failures in U.S history
Rising interest rates caused loans and
Investments to lose value all three of
these Banks catered to wealthy clients
with large uninsured deposits more prone
to withdraw them in times of stress we
had a structure of near zero interest
rates for 20 years and when you begin to
reset those especially very quickly
which the FED has under pressure from
the inflation debates that we've had
you're going to have structures that
evolved under low interest rates that
don't meet the challenges of a new
environment very well of a higher
interest rates the Federal Reserve meets
later this week to decide whether or not
to continue that policy of raising
interest rates at the White House
President Joe Biden attempted to
reassure depositors in the American
public their money is safe
these actions are going to make sure
that the bank assistant is safe and
sound
and that includes protecting small
businesses across the country who need
to make payroll for workers and their
small businesses
while Rising interest rates may continue
to make financial institutions reluctant
to loan money Federal Regulators are
hoping that this allows the country to
put the banking crisis behind them one
clear winner in all of this is of course
JPMorgan Chase it was already the United
States largest bank now with this
acquisition it's even larger Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera New York